well we want to remind you cause we hate
to forget things and history matters
that when this fake hate crime first
happened air quotes joe biden who was
running for the presidency at the time
tweeted this quote what happened today
to jesse smalla must never be tolerated
in this country
we are with you jesse
the question is is the president united
states still with jesse
will he amend that tweet
the meantime for a recap on what we just
saw will kane he's co-host of fox and
friends weekend he's also what's the
phrase an eminent lawyer and we're
really happy to have him with us tonight
well thanks so much for coming out so
what do you make of this what have we
learned
well unfortunately i don't think you've
called me in for any great legal
analysis of the commerce clause or how
it's been tortured for federal power
you've more called me in to analyze my
cousin vinnie it's not to kill a
mockingbird this is a comedy
this is a comedy
and it's more it's less about the law
and it's more about narcissism you know
if there is an intersection tucker it's
that jesse decided to take the stand
which is shocking i guess it's shocking
but he's been performing his way through
life he's been performing his way into
and out of success and he sat in front
of robin roberts and put on an amazing
performance for gma so i guess he
thought he could put on a performance
for a jury but what we found out is that
juries across america several times now
over the last several months have proven
to be more intelligent and more just in
studios in television studios in new
york city and i think we've seen that
with jesse smollett with cal rittenhouse
and with ahmad arbory trust the american
justice system
that is such a wise point and your
original point that this is about
narcissism as virtually everything bad
in this whole moment is about narcissism
will you expand on that a little bit
yeah i think everybody in this entire
melodrama is playing for their own
benefit so let's go back to joe biden
joe biden the american media kamala
harris they're not marx they're they
weren't conned they weren't duped in my
mind they were accomplices to a race
hoax with jesse smollett smollett's
incentives were clear he could only
achieve so much fame by starring an
empire he played to the incentive of
america which is to be the victim of a
race crime put you exactly on the
highest pedestal but look so did joe
biden the american media they played
into something that confirmed their
world view and their role as heroes in
this racist country they played it for
their own benefit so and by the way both
were perfectly willing to sacrifice the
victims of real race crimes they were
both perfectly willing to sacrifice
tearing this country apart along racial
lines for their own benefit for their
own validation
man is that smart i'm pounding the desk
beneath the camera
a lot of impressive people come out of
fox and friend weekend
i'm here to tell you that was so great
thank you will kane good to see you
tonight thank you thanks man hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else